hello and welcome my name is rich Slav
it's not on the slides too hard to spell
even for me so I'm here too I was
supposed to be here to give this talk
but when I was starting I started to
make slides I realized that I actually
want to give a slightly different talk
so I changed this is a very shaky but ok
I changed the title so I'm gonna be
talking here about my experience for the
past six years with some brief
excursions into other projects for the
past six years I worked on the art
programming language mostly on the
Virtual Machine side of it mostly on the
compiler part of the virtual machine and
I want to share some of the developments
and insights from this time how many
people here know what dart is - you know
is ok so everybody who showed up
actually knows what dart is okay that
explains it so before I joined Google I
worked on some Java compiler gel virtual
machine and then I joined Google and
worked on v8 and I had a brief time when
I worked at on lower GT at Google but
most of the time since 2012 I work in a
dart VM and that's my spirit animal up
there in the corner
so ok dart was released in 2011 as as a
language which was supposed to fix web
development at least that's what people
who made it who designed it thought it's
gonna do and everybody here knows what
the artists are almost everybody but for
the benefit of people who will be
watching the recording I'm still going
to show a couple of slides about dart to
show a bit of a problematic side of that
I would say so this is a completely
valid code in dart one
it would compile and it would run maybe
it would throw a runtime error but maybe
it would not throw maybe it would even
actually print something valid so dart
man was an extremely dynamic language
it's essentially kind of a small talk
wrapped into a C syntax because that's
what the original designers of the
language thought is a good programming
model and the types in the program no
meaning except for kind of a link rules
that you can throw on top and validate
your program ahead of time but in
runtime they were completely thrown out
and thrown out and they would not
influence the runtime behavior of the
program so it was a bit of a strange
language so and the reason for doing
dart like that was that dynamic
languages they believed to be very good
for fast iterative development and they
also believed not to be so good for
maintenance
later so the idea was that you will
combine this kind of type system thrown
on top of a dynamic language to have a
maintainability but also very fast
development and well the intent was good
I don't know whether the execution was
good or not the history apparently shows
that people prefer more static languages
but I will talk about that a bit later
so people who designed dart originally
they worked on various VMs in their life
and they worked on Smalltalk Liam's
originally and then they worked on
hotspot so of course they designed the
language in a way that it's very easy
and very efficiently can be implemented
using just-in-time compilation that was
the idea and
when the AVM was originally made it will
it had just the ast based JIT compiler
which took abstract syntax tree produced
by the parser and it compiled it into
the machine code one path code
generation how many people here have any
background in compilers so that I can
also okay that's then I I will also
bypass some of the explanations and
people who watch I guess we'll have to
study something on the side pause the
video so okay i have a 150 slides to go
through so i will I will I will have to
bypass some explanations otherwise we
will never finish okay so in 2012 the
decision was made to start a new jet
compiler because obviously the ASD based
one pass code generation only gets you
so far
and I joined the project then with a
couple of other people all three of us
we came from v8 we worked on the
crankshaft which was the optimizing
compiler for v8 for a long time and we
brought some of the insights that we got
from there and started working on a new
GT compiler and the recipe for doing
good compilers for dynamic languages
these days is well known to everybody
and it has been well known since 90s so
I'm not gonna if you have all of you
have background I'm not going to tell
you something that you don't know you
take some sort of type feedback runtime
feedback collection infrastructure and
you put some speculation on top and you
have some optimized reoptimize machinery
and that's it you have the best JIT you
can ever make nobody can make a better
cheat so it's like all the cheats if you
look at them they are built in the same
way the the way they collect feedback
might be different the way they apply
speculations may be different but the
architecture is always the same even
tracing cheats are essentially the same
stuff is just the granularity of what
you compile and how
compiled it is different so here's some
assembly on the slide so the the the the
way you collect feedback in the in the
dart VM is very simple so let's start at
the top instruction now so okay I have a
high-level description so each call site
in the program has two things associated
with it you have some sort of a data
structure on the side which will contain
the mapping about the classes of the
receivers that were observed this call
site and the targets of the method
invocation so for example we got a real
dog class it will be recorded that there
was a real dog class and the method
invocation went and hit this particular
method in the dog class hierarchy and
and you have a piece of code that
performs a sort of a cache look up it
checks whether something is already in
the cache if it's not in the cache then
you need to do a generic lookup and
otherwise you just reuse the what's
already in the cache and the idea here
is that looking up through the class
hierarchy might be expensive might
involve a lot of lookups and if you just
check if something in the cache that's
much faster so you replace you apply
essentially the technology optimization
that is well-known it's like
memorization no no different from that
so I'm going to illustrate how it works
so you you've got a real doc with a
method woof
so initially you arrive the cache is
empty you go to the slow lookup which
then goes and updates the cache and you
in the cache have the fact that if you
see ever again an instance of a dog then
this is the method that you should be
invoking and there is also a counter
which counts how often have you seen
this particular class which will be
helpful in optimizations later because
you can use some frequency based
algorithms to decide like you how you
schedule the code or how you align the
branches in the decision tree and so on
so forth
so and you if you come again you just
hit the cache and you increment the
counter and you invoke the method and
that's it so on so forth so if you
suddenly get a wolf which completely
unrelated class but because dart is a
dynamically typed language dart one is a
dynamically typed language you can use
completely unrelated classes in the same
call side so you come you look at the
cache it's not in the cache so you hit
the slow path you update the cache and
now that suddenly there is a wolf and it
has only cured once and so on so forth
so this is how the type profiling works
in dart VM so what happens if you later
observe that some code is hot like you
have some cold site in some method and
this is a hot method because you can see
here it was invoked at least a thousand
times so you come and you invoke a
compiler and you start optimizing and
the you use the type feedback to feed
information to your compiler and the
compiler dances well I only saw dogs
there so I will just insert a check
there which checks if it's a dog or not
and I will just do a static call like no
dynamic dispatch to the method and and
that's it of course it's a speculative
optimization you don't know if it's
gonna be true or not so you also have
some machinery for going back to an
optimized code and stuff like that so
this is all fundamentally primitive
stuff it's a classical stuff like Bach
is a classical music this is a bar of
JIT compilers this is the paper from
1991 by the Titans of compilation the
soils let Craig chambers and David Unger
who describe roughly all the same stuff
and it was applied and selves it was
applied and small talk Lars bak who
started both v8 and dart unsurprisingly
worked with all soils layer on one of
the startups they
before well the father's went to Sun
Microsystems and later to Google okay so
but it is a surprisingly general
optimization when we started applying it
to Dart
we first were a little bit confused how
to use it in certain places because
originally when you look at it you think
oh it's just about method calls but then
it turns out many things are actually
can be looked at like they are method
call even though they don't look like
one so for example dark has this
interesting feature so from the call
side you don't actually know whether
that's a method call or it's a field
access and the field contains a closure
so previously I showed you the cases
where there was a class doc and it had a
method whoof but here it's a class alien
it's an alien dog and instead of a
method wolf it contains field which you
can put a closure in and then the code
above should continue to work just the
same it should invoke this method well
in this closure and it should print
stuff so how do you cache the results of
this for example another interesting
feature of dart is that there is an
inverse situation something looks like a
field access but it is actually a
creation of a closure so that has the
shot hand where if you have a method on
the class you can tear it off and
tearing it off binds it to the instance
of the class so it's like if you
programmed in the in JavaScript it's
like dot binds or stuff like that it's
like if you think that method is carried
stuff then it's like applying it one
special application anyway so this
feature again it looks like a field
access but it's actually something else
you create a closure there and finally
there are these no such method
invocations because you can have
something that looks like a method call
but there are no methods in the class
and instead there is a no such method
thing which captures all the invitations
how do you catch that so we come down
the cache is empty we go to look up in
cash
there is no methods we can do something
to invoke the no such method but there
is actually no real method to invoke
like it has completely different
signature so you cannot really cash it
so there's nothing to put in into the
cash so instead you just continue going
and going and going into this runtime
thing and that's where your performance
just completely disappears so we started
looking at it and then we asked
ourselves is there anything that we
could actually put into that cash and
then we said well we are cheap compiler
system so we can actually also generate
kind of a dart code as well and inject
it into the definition of a class and
here we inject the the thing that just
forwards to the no such method and as
soon as you have some dynamically
injected methods now you can actually
cache it in the in the cache and you put
it in and everything just continues to
work from there and when I say
everything it's like if your whole
compilation pipeline is based on this
type feedback suddenly inliner will come
and it will look at the cache and okay
we invoke in only this method so I can
maybe inline it and then you inline it
then you do some constant forwarding
load to store forwarding start to load
and suddenly everything disappears like
that if will disappear and you just you
are left with a print statement the
overhead of there's no such method
completely evaporated okay so what I
told you now in these 47 slides was
basically the work we have done in
2012/2013 and the GT at that point was
kind of done it was doing a good job we
did a few non classical optimizations
because previously what I showed you was
essentially I had a classical
optimization so bending your worldview
in a way which allows you to to use
classical optimizations for slightly non
classical things so we looked at the
code that our compiler generates and we
observed that
I mean by doing this sort of speculative
optimizations you add checks on the used
sides usually because when you invoke
something on an object of unknown type
and you cannot establish the type of
this object some using some local type
propagation then you are forced to put
some sort of a check in there which will
cause the optimization if it's it does
not hold so we started thinking about
how to move these checks from the use
side to the definition because usually
you in a place where this value comes
from you know what type it has like and
one good example is values that come
from fields a lot of failures actually
come from fields and when you create
objects yes a check at use when you
create objects and you feel the fields
you usually know what you're putting in
those fields in one way or another
either you copied them from other fields
or you create them right there so we
decided to assign a bit of a state to
each field in the each class and that
state captures what kind of values are
stored into this field across all
objects in the heap so if we ever read
from this field what kind of state can
we get and we record three types of
information that can treat class of a
value whether it's an owl or not
potentially because dart is is a
language with now unfortunately and and
all values and a Lebel and we also
record lengths of an array
if there is an array always start into
this field because that allows you to
eliminate bounced checks and when we
have a load we just look is there some
state recorded for this field and use
this information to eliminate any checks
of the use of the field and when you
store you need to update this state and
you need to optimize the code that
depends on it if you are doing an
incompatible update but the observation
here is that when you are storing
usually you can eliminate the
checks because you know the type of what
you're storing in in one way or another
so the overhead kind of disappears and
overhead from the users also disappears
so in this particular example we would
know that one of the fields is always
non out dog and has no length I mean
dogs have different lengths and for the
list of dogs you know that it's always
the least it's always known now on it
has ten elements so if you ever have an
access to this list with an index that
is a constant unknown because of the
range analysis it tells it's a range
between 1 and between 0 and 9 then you
don't need to do a bounced check ok so
yeah that's the summary of this
optimization in 2013 five years ago in
exactly this room I told I gave a talk
about our experience building the the
JIT faux Dart I mostly focus on v8
though and how we did not do the
mistakes we didn't deviate so if you're
curious too you can go check this talk
ok 2014 we spent mostly just tweaking
things we did not do much just improving
the optimizations no real innovation we
started this say no to the handwritten
assembly effort in 2014 because in the
in the dart VM we had this compiler on
the side and we had some code that was
written in assembly by hand and usually
if you have can read an assembly that's
where all the bugs would be you want to
update some calling convention somewhere
suddenly some register is used in a
place where you did not expect and you
have a back which happens once in a
while because somebody is using the
wrong register so we started porting all
our handwritten assembly to the to use
the compiler itself because well you
have this optimizing compiler which you
say it's great at optimizing things well
then you should be eating your own dog
food and actually using it to produce
the code that you are writing by hand
and I think a lot of the virtual
machines actually moving in the same
direction like create is using the the
code stub assembler these days it's
called to generate their stops and entry
in 6:00 we plan to move our stops and
when I say stops it's just a piece of
assembly code which is not like a
doesn't correspond to a function and the
dart program is just that exceeded every
piece of assembly code we started to
move them to but then we had to abandon
it because we got distracted bitten by
some other projects we also did a export
and irrigates with the website of that
so yeah so array X is a regular
expression engine which originally came
from v8 when we started dart VM we did
not use that because it's completely
ingrained into the v8 internals so we
just use pcre
which is ok but it's slow and maybe it
was slow maybe they fixed it I don't
know and it also does not completely
match the JavaScript semantics of
regular expressions so we decided that
we want to use the reg X because it's
good and it's fast and it matches the
JavaScript semantics but we did not want
to take its back-end and the way a reg
express written is that it takes regular
expression and produces some
intermediate representation of a regular
expression and then it compiles it to
machine code and that compilation to
machine code was completely platform
specific so if you have MIPS back-end
you need to write it by hand in MIPS
assembly well we are not a big fans of
that so the way we did it is we just
generated the compiler intermediate
representation from the intermediate
representation of the regular expression
compilation engine and this way we only
had to take the front part of it and the
middle part of it and back ends we got
for free and the performance is quite
acceptable it's not as fast sometimes as
V aids because v8 has hand allocated
registers and everything like that and
we did not do anything
like that in in the dart VM version and
we actually even starts from an
optimized version of regular expression
that mean it warms up and optimizes it
even though the types are kind of known
statically so you have this if you use
the same regular expression a lot of
times then you see how the performance
goes like that but it starts slower so
but it was a quick in turn projects
entually and it just shows that if you
have a high-level compiler which can
take some high level representation
while it's better to use that instead of
writing assembly okay so somewhere on
the in the beginning of the presentation
I have said that well dart was supposed
to be a web development language and I'm
talking and talking about the VM well
how does it even work because no VA no
no browser actually includes the virtual
machine well the way it worked is that
there are two ways to run dart code
there is a native way which we hoped
that some browsers would use but that
did not come to pass so there is a
fallback way you can compile to
JavaScript and as we were evolving the
virtual machine the dart2js compiler
compilation technology was also evolving
so it started in this AST based compiler
written in Java which obviously was not
so amazing then there was a we like cool
names like dart frog frog was the dis
attempt to compile a dart to JavaScript
without actually respecting its
semantics that's why I say it's
transpiler because I hate the word
transpiler and I think that if you call
your if you are working on transpiler
that usually means that you're using
regular expressions to compile your
stuff so search and replace so then
there was the leg of a frog which was
the SSA based CFG SSA based compiler
written in dart and then because people
were very confused about the naming
they were like should I use proxy or
Lexi or what is happening so we rename
it to dar two GS and it's a big ahead of
time compiler with SSA type flow
analysis inside which takes forever to
compile dart programs and that's not
because it's a bad compiler it's because
actually if you look at the language you
realize that it's so dynamic and so
flexible that compiling it ahead of time
is hard you just don't have the type
information so you need to run some sort
of analysis to derive this type
information and usually those analysis
they don't scale very well and you have
a problem that the language you are
targeting it neither matches your source
language so you cannot do this regular
expression style compilation no it has
enough flexibility for you to erase or
like represent these mismatches in the
efficient way because it's JavaScript
right so okay so in 2014 something
interesting happens which we did not
expect in the sky has opened so the a
group of people on the chrome team
originally they departed on a very
interesting experiment they thought
there are a lot of mobile web there are
a lot of frameworks for developing
mobile applications which would work
across iOS and Android but all of them a
bit lacking in different parts so they
are there for example web view based
frameworks where you just use web
technology and you wrap it in an app or
they're a native ones where you just
have to write essentially two
applications and they said well what if
we take a web view technology because
that's what we worked on we worked for
like tens of years on the on the
optimizing the rendering pipelines in in
browsers and we actually strip away all
the legacy all the CSS all the HTML and
stuff like that and you just left with
the core of the layout and rendering the
raw
Beats or textures and how fast that can
be how small that can be and they
started working on that and it was
called sky originally and it actually
used javascript in the beginning because
they just started with Chrome and then
they started cutting things down down
down eventually they cut the JavaScript
out and put dart in amazing and the C++
is still there but it's only used for
the lowest parts of the system where you
push the stuff to the GPUs essentially
but the layout and like scene rendering
the upper parts of it are all done in
dart and they renamed it to flatter so
that's the flutter so if you never heard
about flatter how many people heard
about flatter everybody right I'm not
telling you anything new so okay so
there was also talk in 2017 on strange
loop very modestly named framework of
the tomorrow you should check it out
it's a great talk and Eric is a great
speaker
okay so you figured out already by now
that this is the mobile development
framework okay but that also means that
we have an interesting challenge here
because there are two major operating
systems for mobile phones Android and
iOS and Android is great it allows you
to take your dart VM put it in and off
you go
iOS does not unless you have Mobile
Safari then you are signed in a special
way and then you can do cheating and
this is a security measure so I can
understand that
maybe not but okay so and and that
creates a problem for us because we have
this amazing mobile development
framework based on dart but we cannot
run it on iOS because our dart to native
compilation technology is all just in
time based so we need an ahead of time
solution so in 2015
me and another colleague of mine we
started working on the prototype of
annuity Kampai
and the the observation that we made
when we started working on it is that
well actually we already have a lot of
interesting pieces in place because we
generate this JIT code and this JIT code
doesn't actually embed any pointers into
the garbage collected heap there is an
indirection in between called an object
pool and that means that the JIT code is
relocatable
you just you save the JIT code and then
you just when you load that you need to
hook it up to the right pool and off you
go there is still a little bit of
complexity because you cannot have the
pointer to the object pool in the
instructions themselves like it was
originally because you're gonna mark the
instructions regions read-only so you
have to do some massaging and stuff like
that change the calling conventions
which actually regress the performance
of the JIT because we we we do not want
to have flags that say are we compiling
for the AO t then use this calling
convention are we compiling for the JIT
use these calling conventions because we
thought if you don't have these flags
and it's easier to test the code because
then you test the same calling
convention across all the modes of
execution so but that was a mistake in a
respect because it regrets the JIT
performance so and once you fixed all of
this stuff and your code became
completely relocatable you just write it
out and we already had the technology
for that called snapshots it's like you
take a heap dump of your VM and then you
can hydrate it back if you need it so we
hook this all up together except there
is a problem the JIT compiler is lazy
and it generates speculative code right
so how do we get the code to serialize
like we have this technology to
serialize the code but you don't have
the code anymore yet let's say because
when you start with that program nothing
is actually compiled it's compiled as it
is being executed so well the solution
again is very simple you just disable
speculations all that you can find and
then you force compile everything
starting from the root of like main and
then you go around and you
everything that can potentially be
executed okay and it was actually very
fast thing to do like because we already
had so many pieces in place and we had
this powerful compilation pipeline and
so and so forth so only two three months
we already had a narrative compiler in
hand and we could run stuff on iOS well
of course in reality took another
probably four to six months to make a
real product out of it
so because as you remember eighty
compilation of dart to JavaScript is
hard and no matter where you go you
actually have problem because of the
dart semantics you need to have some
solutions for this dynamism and we be
able to eliminate it or alleviate the
cost of dynamism and in the code that
you generate okay so the the Jeep
compensated for this dynamism using
speculative optimizations so you need a
new disabled that part so you need to
replace it with something so the
solution for the for the for the first
version of a compiler that we had was to
essentially use kind of inline caching
in the 80 generated code and as you
remember you have these two pieces
attached to each call side in reality
they are accessed through the
indirection as I described before which
means that you can patch them as you run
the thing you cannot patch update the
code but you can write patch these two
pieces for each call side meaning that
you can change the state of this call
site as you executing and you observing
what's happening and it's again very
classical thing so I'm not going to stop
on it also because I'm running off time
out of time right yeah I have three in
seven minutes so I will just keep all
the slides we also did the salmon lining
for arithmetic because in dart you would
say oh arithmetic should be simple but
in reality in dart you can overwrite
operators so if you see a plus in the
program that doesn't mean it's an
arithmetic at all it can be
I don't know list concatenation int type
is malleable and in toaster has
arbitrary
so you can take one shifted by a
thousand shifted back is to need to get
one so there's some assembly you can
look at it when they publish the slides
it doesn't really matter but you just
put some fast paths for their athletic
operation and then on the slow section
of the code far away from the hot path
you put some generic fallback nothing
special really okay and we edit on top a
little bit of closed world optimizations
no real type flow analysis because we
Bay based this technology on our JIT so
it's essentially kind of ahead of time
JIT with some parameters optimizations
but no really good closed world type
flow for example okay there is an
interesting problem that you hit when
you compile ahead of time is that you
really want to have small binaries you
don't want to have a lot of for example
fallback code otherwise you could just
generate fast paths everywhere then slow
pass everywhere you want to have a
generic code which is reasonably fast
and reasonably small we got an
interesting benefit from this
indirection
because if you think about it then all
methods like all non inline
non-specialized call sides they look all
exactly the same given that you have the
same registers for the dock and stuff
like that so if you look at these two
functions in and you assume that they
cannot be specialized in any way then
actually compiled to exactly the same
machine code so you can share that code
in the resulting binary and the only
thing that is different is the object
pool content so that cuts the binary
size quite considerably at least by 10
to 20 percent the byproduct of the AIT
work was very interesting side effect is
that we can now warm up an application
then save the state of a heap and then
start from there which cuts on the warm
up cost for the programs that run in the
JIT mode okay but only so much can be
done and only so much can be set in five
minutes but I will try so in 2016 the
wind started blowing the wind of changes
for dart it was observed the dart2js is
very slow for the development cycles if
you are developing in the browser if you
start to GS you will die
for the large program is compiled so
they have been cooking on the website
separate compiler which was supposed to
do fast modular compilations but those
fast modular compilations they require a
richer type system because you cannot
really compile modular leap and produce
reasonable size and performance code if
you know nothing about the types in the
whole program so they said what if dart
was a reasonable programming language
like Java no not really like that but
yeah so what if the writing that
variable is a dog actually guaranteed
that variable is a dog what if Kevin a
list of cats actually guarantee that
there is a cat inside none of which was
true for dart one so there is a talk
from 2013 on the dart conf by Leif
Patterson who some of you might know as
the person who worked on Intel Haskell
compiler at some point so all the
insinuations about Java type system are
not completely true but anyway so there
is a talk about evolution of the dart
language so and it was another problem
with the dart ecosystem is that every
dart tool had its own dart parser
basically so everybody started from dart
source and then if your VM then you
parse it if you dare to jsut parse it if
you don't analyzer you parse it and then
off you go
which created considerable complexity if
you want to evolve the language and you
want to change the new type system
suddenly need to fix a lot of different
parsers and stuff like that so we
started a project to unify it and make
like single binary HT representation
which can be shared between different
backends and tools and so on so
immigration started in 2016 and then for
nothing but two years we did this
migration so we worked on nothing else
essentially and it's turned out to be a
complete sinkhole of engineering time
and which we didn't expect but in
retrospect doing two migrations at the
same time to a new type system and to a
new combination infrastructure is hard
so tons of good gnarly work but we did
some cool work as well too because
moving some stuff into dart like we
started parsing dart in
art allowed us to also do 4vm
optimization passes in dart for example
that was cool because t+ pass is not the
most pleasant language to write coding
the era T in dart too became simpler but
still there are problems because
primitive types are still now about the
int became from a big integer to a
64-bit integer but also t2 bit platforms
you still have a problem with that
because you you need to represent it as
a pair and stuff like that and the
soundness requires type checks so it's a
soundness because like well it's a
reasonable type system for them which
was retrofitted on a tons of an existing
code so you couldn't just make it
completely strict you had to do some
stuff I'm gonna have two minutes so I'll
try to tell you this so dark half
covariant generics and if you have
covered in generics you have to check so
if you have a programmed in Java you
know that if you have covariant erase
you store into array you get a store
exception if the array of of the wrong
type the same and dart accepts all
generics a covariant welcome to my world
and there is also a still dynamic
functionality in that so you can have a
dynamic type which is allows you to call
anything on on itself and that is all
checked in runtime so you need some
solution to that and I'm not going to go
too much details into that but it's
essentially reusing the same technology
you have some stops that forward things
and check things or you have multiple
entry points into the function which
bypass checks and you use some static or
dynamic analysis to determine which
entry point you use in the nth apt
compiler like this is what happened
today and so eighty compiler in usually
it's much faster now like the code that
it produces much better and the code is
much faster so that's almost the end of
it so there are some learnings I want to
tell you but I will overrun by two
minutes it's okay you're not gonna kick
me out right no ok perfect so we have 20
minutes between the talk so to means I
cannot run so what
learned is that if you change in
architecture usually think oh it's gonna
take one night it takes two years if you
think it will take two days it will take
four probably so so you better have your
key textured structured in such a way
that you have some parameters and it's
not completely all fixed so that you can
tweak it much easier I mean this is all
basic stuff most of the optimizations
are more general than you think like you
you think you can only apply inline
caching for method calls in reality you
can apply it to almost everything
including the elimination of type checks
of a cavalry and generics which you
never anticipated when you started to
implement it there are still interesting
problems in compiler technology to solve
nobody writes about code size reductions
everybody writes about how to make the
tightest smallest possible code how does
it compile something how do you do it in
any context how do you outline stuff
like a noodle VM people are working on
outlining but in reality it's and Scala
native I think are also working on that
but there are very little published
about this so if you are student working
this area this is thing to focus on and
if you have your own compiler don't ever
write assembly by hand if your compiler
is incapable of producing the reasonable
code retire so there is no thing to
slide by thank you for the attention
[Applause]